they are the first of many to come
ash cupboard holy men are heading
towards a special part of the Ganges
River to perform a deeply spiritual
ritual in waters they consider holy
[Applause]
the sunrise marks the official beginning
of the Camela and more pilgrims arrive
Hindus believe that bathing here during
this time will wash away their sins and
help them reach Hinduism's ultimate
spiritual goal salvation from the cycle
of life and death it is said that if you
bathe at the confluence of these rivers
during the time of come you attain
nirvana receive blessings and all your
wishes are fulfilled the Camela draws on
centuries of Hindu tradition but even
among young people today the ancient
ritual is hugely popular since my
childhood I used to hear stories about
the comb from my grandparents this is
the land of meditation of millions of
sages and holy men I feel privileged to
have bathed in this confluence of rivers
today managing the crowds is a mammoth
task portable toilets lined the dusty
roads and a special tented city has been
set up to accommodate the pilgrims
festival officials say India's Hindu
nationalist government has made it a
priority to make the festival a success
the vision of the government was to make
sure that the Hindi inherited the Indian
culture the comb heroism which actually
personifies what India is is is shown to
the entire world pilgrims who come here
have a great experience Prime Minister
Narendra Modi his party's up for
re-election is expected to join the
pilgrims
during the eight-week festival